how are you doing today hey i'm great i
love your collection
uh it's a matte painting actually oh
that's so cool i'm joking i'm joking
so let me let me start by saying
congrats on season two i've i've watched
it and uh it's uh uh excellent that's
noah you know that's my word for it
thank you i appreciate that uh so the
writers gave you what i'm gonna call a
great storyline this season
and i'm curious what can you tease for
fans of the show
um you know i think it's about
exploration of identity this this season
really explores lots of different topics
whether it's systemic racism it's
homophobia
it's abuse of power
um
my character is going on she's sort of
having an identity crisis she's suddenly
come into a position of power at the
network she's on air she's the number
one anchor but her ratings are terrible
and she's on the slow discovery to find
herself and
um sort of is starting to find herself
through a new relationship so it's very
exciting and i can't say too much about
it but it's very cool
yeah i would love to talk specifics but
i will not
well maybe we can talk again at some
other point
uh i am curious do you view corey as a
good person a bad person or does it
depend on the day of the week
oh i try not to be too binary about any
human because i think we are all just
human we all are capable of really
horrible things and really amazing
things so corey is just um an incredibly
ambitious machiavellian you know media
architect that is
really trying to see into the future but
manage his personal feelings about all
the players involved so and he has a few
feelings but not a lot
i completely agree with that um you have
some really emotionally charged scenes
this season and i'm curious and i love
talking to actors about how they prepare
for for scenes like that i'm curious
like say you're filming something that
you know is going to be challenging on a
monday
how are you the day before or the night
before in terms of thinking about that
are you like in your head and how much
is it sort of like i'm not gonna think
about it but i'm gonna go to set early
and really get into it
yeah oh my god that's such a good
question because every actor processes
so differently but my process is sort of
like i have panic three days before a
really hard scene then two days before
i'll be really studious and study it and
really think about it the last night
before i read through it once and then i
try to rid my mind of any stress or
pressure and then the morning of
i just i feel like i almost like prepare
for it like i'm preparing for
um like you would prepare for an
argument with your boss or something
like you have to gird yourself and then
i just do the scene but that is my
process it's like a four-day process and
i think my husband he's like
okay i can tell you're really going
through this and so i warn my family i'm
like i have some really tough scenes
next week so just no
don't take anything personally
uh obviously as a fan of the show i am
curious about a season three and you are
a very key person involved in this
series uh in producing and everything um
where where are you guys um what can you
tease people about a possible season
three
well i think season three is you know
definitely it's all on our minds we're
definitely planning for it but it just
has to hit the same bar with season one
we were talking about me too
women in the workplace it was almost
like we were preparing for the
revolution and then at the very end the
revolution happened season two is sort
of like what happens who becomes in
charge after a revolution who creates
the constitution for this new world
order and then season three i think we
have to tackle something just as big as
that so
i can't imagine what it is we haven't
gotten there yet but i'm really excited
just for the amount of topical um
contemporary concerns that we have in
workplace dynamics i think it's a really
great show for that
100 thank you so much for your time and
again congrats on a great season thank
you for your thoughtful questions